- Bienvenue dans Comprendre
l'information et le calcul quantiques.
Je m'appelle John Watrous, et je suis le directeur technique
de IBM Quantum Education.
Le but de cette série est de te donner
une solide compréhension de l'information et du calcul quantiques, ce qui implique d'entrer
dans les détails techniques
de l'information quantique et de voir comment le calcul
quantique fonctionne vraiment, ce qu'il peut faire et ce qu'il ne peut pas faire.
Si tu n'as pas encore
regardé la vidéo de présentation de cette série, je t'encourage à y jeter un œil.
Dans cette vidéo, tu trouveras des informations sur le type de prérequis
recommandés pour cette série, ainsi qu'un aperçu
des sujets qui seront couverts.
N'oublie pas non plus de consulter
le manuel Qiskit, qui couvre le même
contenu que cette série de vidéos sous forme écrite,
et qui inclut aussi
des composants interactifs et des interfaces vers du matériel et des logiciels conçus pour t'aider à mieux comprendre
l'information et le calcul quantiques. Tu trouveras des liens vers la vidéo de présentation et le manuel Qiskit
dans la description.
Ceci est la leçon un de
l'unité un de la série.
L'unité un couvre les bases
de l'information quantique, et dans la première leçon de cette unité, nous nous concentrerons sur le fonctionnement
de l'information quantique
pour les systèmes simples, c'est-à-dire que nous avons
un seul système physique ou un dispositif quelconque qui
stocke de l'information quantique
et nous examinons comment ce
système ou dispositif fonctionne de façon isolée.
Dans la leçon suivante, nous verrons comment
l'information quantique fonctionne lorsqu'on a plusieurs systèmes, ce qui nous permettra
de décrire des concepts
intéressants et importants tels que les algorithmes quantiques qui utilisent plusieurs qubits
et les protocoles quantiques
impliquant plusieurs individus qui traitent l'information quantique et se la transmettent
mutuellement.
Mais avant d'aborder ces discussions, il est logique de commencer par le
cadre relativement simple d'un système unique en isolation,
en partie parce qu'il est bon de commencer simplement, mais aussi parce que, comme nous le verrons, la description du fonctionnement
de l'information quantique
pour les systèmes simples en isolation mène très naturellement et logiquement à la description du fonctionnement
pour les systèmes multiples.
Voici un bref aperçu de la leçon.
Nous allons commencer par discuter
de l'information classique.
Le but de cette leçon n'est pas d'expliquer comment
fonctionne l'information classique, mais d'expliquer comment
fonctionne l'information quantique,
mais pour expliquer comment
fonctionne l'information quantique, il est très utile de commencer
par l'information classique et de l'utiliser comme point de référence familier
lorsque nous abordons l'information quantique.
Sur le plan mathématique, l'information quantique et l'information classique ont en fait des descriptions assez similaires, avec quelques différences clés, bien entendu.
En fait, l'information quantique
n'est pas vraiment séparée de l'information classique.
C'est une extension de
l'information classique.
La réalité, du moins selon moi, c'est qu'on ne peut vraiment pas
comprendre l'information quantique si on ne comprend pas
l'information classique,
donc commencer par l'information classique
a du sens.
Je m'attends à ce que ce
contenu soit familier pour certains spectateurs, mais même si c'est le cas, je ne recommande pas de le passer.
En plus de mettre en évidence les aspects de l'information classique les plus pertinents pour
comprendre l'information quantique, nous allons introduire la
notation de Dirac dans cette partie,
qui est une manière standard
que nous allons utiliser pour décrire les vecteurs et
les matrices tout au long de la série.
Il s'avère que la notation de Dirac n'est pas
spécifique à l'information quantique.
Elle peut tout aussi bien être utilisée dans le contexte de l'information classique ainsi que dans de nombreux autres contextes où des vecteurs et des matrices apparaissent.
Nous passerons ensuite à l'information quantique, et en particulier, nous
discuterons de la représentation des états quantiques sous forme de vecteurs,
un type simple de mesure appelé mesure en base standard, et des opérations unitaires, qui décrivent les changements temporels discrets
dans les systèmes quantiques.
Le tout dans le contexte
des systèmes simples.
Avant de commencer la leçon elle-même, il sera utile de clarifier qu'il existe en réalité deux descriptions
de l'information quantique : la description simplifiée, qui est ce sur quoi nous allons
nous concentrer dans cette leçon
et tout au long de cette première unité, et la description générale, qui est couverte dans une unité ultérieure, spécifiquement dans la
troisième unité de la série.
La description simplifiée,
fidèle à son nom, est plus simple et c'est
généralement celle qu'on apprend en premier.
Dans la description simplifiée, comme je l'ai déjà suggéré, les états quantiques sont représentés par des vecteurs et les opérations sont représentées
par des matrices unitaires.
Cette description de l'information
quantique est suffisante pour comprendre
la plupart des algorithmes quantiques, par exemple,
donc ce n'est pas une simplification excessive, c'est la vraie chose.
Cependant, comme nous le
découvrirons au fur et à mesure, elle a certaines limitations.
Par exemple, si nous voulons
modéliser les effets du bruit sur les systèmes quantiques, cette description s'avère insuffisante.
WEBVTT
La description générale, en
revanche, est plus générale et, en définitive, plus
puissante sur le plan mathématique.
Dans cette description, les états quantiques sont représentés par une classe spéciale de matrices
appelées matrices densité,
et une classe plus générale de
mesures et d'opérations peut être décrite, notamment
le bruit, par exemple.
Elle est entièrement cohérente avec
la description simplifiée et en fait, on peut essentiellement voir
la description simplifiée
comme un cas particulier de
la description générale, qui inclut également l'information classique comme cas particulier.
C'est aussi vraiment
beau dans la façon dont tout s'articule, donc je t'encourage vivement à te renseigner sur cette description générale
quand le moment sera venu, mais la description simplifiée est l'endroit le plus naturel pour commencer, et c'est donc ce que nous allons faire.
Nous allons commencer par parler de l'information classique en gardant un œil sur les aspects
de l'information classique les plus pertinents
pour l'information quantique
et sur la façon dont elle est
décrite mathématiquement.
Imaginons que nous avons un
système physique ou un dispositif quelconque qui stocke de l'information.
Nous allons donner à ce système le nom X, mais ce nom n'a
rien d'important.
Nous pourrions utiliser n'importe quel autre
nom si nous le préférions, mais juste pour choisir un nom,
nous allons appeler le système X.
Nous allons faire une hypothèse sur X, à savoir qu'il existe un
ensemble fini d'états classiques dans lesquels X peut éventuellement se
trouver à tout moment donné.
Ici, quand je parle d'un état classique, je veux dire une configuration du système qui peut être reconnue et
décrite sans ambiguïté
sans aucune incertitude ni erreur.
En réalité, c'est quelque chose que tu peux appréhender intuitivement. Sur le plan mathématique, on définit simplement
l'ensemble des états classiques,
on le choisit comme on veut ou de la façon qui décrit le mieux
le dispositif avec lequel on travaille.
Donnons le nom sigma à
cet ensemble d'états classiques, et encore une fois, soulignons
que nous supposons que sigma est un ensemble fini.
L'ensemble des états classiques
de ce système X n'est pas infiniment grand comme
l'ensemble de tous les nombres naturels.
Il est fini, et c'est simplement une
hypothèse que nous faisons.
Par exemple, il pourrait être que X est un bit, auquel cas, l'ensemble des états classiques est l'ensemble contenant deux
éléments : zéro et un.
Parfois, on désigne cet
ensemble comme l'alphabet binaire.
Un autre exemple est que X est
un dé ordinaire à six faces, auquel cas les états classiques sont les nombres un à six.
Bien sûr, on parle
ici d'une abstraction.
Un vrai dé à six faces peut
avoir de nombreux attributs différents comme sa position précise, son orientation,
sa température, etc. Mais en ce qui concerne l'information la plus généralement pertinente lorsqu'on parle d'un dé à six faces,
les états classiques sont
les nombres un à six indiqués par le nombre de points sur la face du dé tournée vers le haut.
Si X est le commutateur d'un
ventilateur électrique standard comme tu pourrais en avoir chez toi, alors peut-être que les états classiques
sont les réglages fort,
moyen, faible et arrêt.
Ce ne sont que des exemples. On pourrait imaginer des systèmes ayant des ensembles d'états classiques différents de ceux-ci, mais ils permettent d'illustrer l'idée
que cette notion d'état classique est quelque chose qui devrait être
familier et peut être compris de façon simple et intuitive.
Mathématiquement parlant, l'ensemble des états classiques
est simplement un ensemble fini, et bien sûr, cet ensemble doit
également être non vide.
Il faut qu'il y ait au moins
un état classique dans lequel le système peut se trouver et il faut qu'il y ait au moins deux états classiques
si le système doit être utile pour stocker de l'information.
Maintenant, dans certaines situations, on pourrait savoir que X est
dans un état particulier, mais dans de nombreuses situations,
qui se produisent dans le cadre
du traitement de l'information, il peut y avoir une incertitude sur l'état classique d'un
système à un moment particulier
de sorte que chaque état classique possible a une certaine probabilité associée.
Par exemple, si X est un bit, alors peut-être que X est dans l'état classique zéro
avec probabilité trois quarts et il est dans l'état un
avec probabilité un quart.
Nous allons appeler cela
un état probabiliste, et nous pourrions exprimer
cet état probabiliste, comme tu le vois ici,
simplement en indiquant quelles
sont les probabilités pour les différents états classiques.
Une façon plus succincte d'exprimer
cet état probabiliste est par un vecteur, spécifiquement la représentation
que tu vois ici
est un vecteur colonne, et ce vecteur indique
quelles sont les probabilités pour les deux états classiques possibles.
Plus précisément, la première entrée indique
quelle est la probabilité pour X d'être dans l'état zéro, et la deuxième entrée nous dit quelle est la probabilité
que le système soit dans l'état un. C'est simplement la façon naturelle d'ordonner l'alphabet binaire,
ou du moins, c'est la façon dont
nous avons appris à le faire. Avec zéro en premier et un en second.
Dorénavant, nous allons utiliser
le terme vecteur de probabilité pour désigner un vecteur comme celui-ci.
WEBVTT
Plus précisément, c'est un vecteur dont toutes les entrées sont des
nombres réels non négatifs et où la somme des
entrées est égale à un,
ce qui a du sens de
considérer ces entrées comme des probabilités.
Dans cet exemple, il n'y a que deux entrées parce qu'il n'y a que deux
états classiques du système dont on parle,
mais en général, il pourrait y avoir
n'importe quel nombre d'entrées, étant entendu
qu'il y a une entrée pour chaque état classique
du système dont on parle.
Nous allons continuer
à discuter de l'information classique, des vecteurs de probabilité et
ainsi de suite dans un moment, mais d'abord, il va être vraiment utile
d'introduire une notation
pour décrire les vecteurs connue sous le nom de notation de Dirac.
En fait, c'est juste la première
partie de la notation de Dirac.
Il y a quelques autres
aspects de la notation de Dirac que nous verrons un peu
plus tard dans la leçon.
Cette notation va être
très centrale dans la façon dont nous décrivons l'information quantique, il est donc essentiel de
comprendre comment elle fonctionne,
mais heureusement, elle est très simple et n'a vraiment
rien de spécifiquement lié à l'information quantique,
donc nous pouvons l'introduire maintenant
dans le contexte familier de l'information classique.
Comme précédemment, on suppose que nous avons un ensemble sigma d'
états classiques d'un système quelconque, et supposons
que nous avons un ordre
de ces états classiques, tout comme nous faisons référence à un
ordre de l'alphabet binaire
dans l'exemple précédent. Une autre façon de dire cela
est que les éléments de sigma sont mis en correspondance
avec l'entier
de un jusqu'au nombre d'
éléments contenus dans sigma, ce que cette notation ici avec deux barres autour de sigma signifie.
C'est le nombre d'
éléments dans l'ensemble sigma.
Il y a donc un premier état,
un deuxième état, et ainsi de suite.
L'ordre spécifique ou la
correspondance que nous choisissons n'aura pas vraiment beaucoup d'importance.
Ce qui est vraiment important, c'est
que nous avons un ordre et que nous nous y tenons.
Pour de nombreux ensembles d'états classiques
que nous rencontrerons, il y aura un ordre standard tout comme nous en avons avec
l'alphabet binaire,
et s'il n'y a pas d'ordre standard, on peut simplement en choisir un.
Mais quoi qu'il en soit, l'idée est que nous nous y tenons.
Voici maintenant la notation
qui est introduite.
Pour tout choix d'un état classique a de notre ensemble sigma, on écrit ceci, ce qui se lit ket a
pour désigner le vecteur colonne
qui a un un dans l'entrée correspondant à a et un zéro pour toutes les autres entrées.
Par exemple, si nous revenons
à l'alphabet binaire, qui, comme tu l'as peut-être deviné, est un exemple très important
auquel nous reviendrons encore et encore. Alors ket zéro et ket un sont les vecteurs définis ici.
Ket zéro est le vecteur
qui a un un dans l'entrée correspondant à l'état classique zéro, qui est la première entrée,
et un zéro pour toutes les autres entrées, et dans ce cas, il n'y a
qu'une seule autre entrée.
De même, ket un est
ce vecteur ici où nous avons un un dans l'
entrée correspondant à un,
qui est la deuxième entrée, et un zéro pour toutes les autres entrées, ce qui, encore une fois, n'est qu'une seule entrée.
Voici un autre exemple. Dans cet exemple, nous avons un ensemble d'états classiques sigma correspondant aux quatre couleurs
d'un jeu de cartes standard : trèfles, carreaux, cœurs et piques.
Dans ce cas, il n'existe pas vraiment d'
ordre universellement accepté pour ces couleurs.
Pour de nombreux jeux de cartes, il n'y a aucun ordre. Ce sont juste quatre couleurs différentes et c'est tout ce qui importe, et il y a différents jeux de cartes qui ordonnent ces couleurs
de différentes façons, mais ça n'a pas vraiment d'importance.
On peut simplement choisir un
ordre comme celui que tu vois ici.
Il s'avère être un ordre alphabétique selon les noms de ces quatre couleurs écrits en anglais,
En supposant que nous avons choisi
cet ordre particulier, nous définissons alors ces quatre vecteurs : ket clubs, ket diamonds,
ket hearts et ket spades
comme tu le vois ici, et ces vecteurs correspondent
à la description générale que tu vois ici.
Étant donné que nous avons choisi
cet ordre particulier pour ces quatre couleurs.
On peut faire la même chose pour tout ensemble d'états classiques
que l'on choisit.
En gardant à l'esprit que l'
ensemble d'états classiques signifie toujours un ensemble fini et non vide.
Les vecteurs de cette forme sont
appelés vecteurs de base standard, et c'est un fait très basique sur les vecteurs que tout vecteur peut être
exprimé de façon unique
comme une combinaison linéaire
de vecteurs de base standard.
Par exemple, en revenant à l'exemple de tout à l'heure, le vecteur de probabilité
que nous avons vu peut être exprimé
comme tu le vois ici. C'est essentiellement une façon alternative d'exprimer des vecteurs
qui va être très pratique pour plusieurs raisons par la suite.
WEBVTT
Et avec cette notation maintenant en main, revenons à la discussion
de l'information classique et des états probabilistes, en particulier.
Et voyons ce qui se passe
lorsqu'on mesure un système alors qu'il est dans un état probabiliste.
Il est possible que nous ne
parlions pas ordinairement d'une mesure ou de l'acte de mesurer
quelque chose dans un cadre classique, mais le terme a du sens.
En essence, quand on parle
de mesurer le système X dans ce contexte, on veut simplement dire qu'on le regarde et qu'on reconnaît l'état dans lequel il se trouve.
Bien sûr, quand on regarde le système, on ne voit pas un état probabiliste, on voit un état classique,
et l'état classique particulier
que l'on voit est celui qu'on peut
imaginer être choisi aléatoirement selon les probabilités.
Maintenant, tu pourrais objecter sur des
bases philosophiques à l'idée que l'état classique que l'on voit soit en quelque sorte choisi au hasard
au moment où on mesure ou où on regarde le système, le système se trouvait simplement dans un état classique particulier tout le temps
et on vient juste d'
apprendre quel était l'état, mais dans l'optique de réfléchir au cadre mathématique
avec lequel on travaille,
il est acceptable de penser ainsi et cela nous permettra de faire un parallèle avec
l'information quantique un peu plus tard.
Supposons que l'
état classique que l'on voit est l'état classique a, qui pourrait être n'importe quel état de notre ensemble sigma.
Cela change l'état probabiliste
de X en général, du moins de notre point de vue.
Les probabilités n'ont plus
aucune signification puisque nous savons maintenant quel
est l'état classique de X.
C'est a, et il n'y a plus
aucune incertitude à ce sujet.
Nous dirions maintenant que
la probabilité que le système soit dans l'état a est un.
Nous le savons parce que nous venons de le regarder et nous avons vu que l'état classique est a, donc le nouvel état probabiliste de X est un
dans lequel la probabilité d'
être dans l'état classique a est égale à un.
Et cet état probabiliste est représenté par le
vecteur de probabilité ket a.
Nous avons un un dans l'entrée correspondant à l'état classique a et un zéro dans toutes les autres entrées.
Par exemple, si nous considérons à nouveau
la situation où X est un bit et que nous avons le même
état probabiliste qu'avant,
alors si nous mesurons X, on peut imaginer qu'une
transition a lieu.
Avec probabilité trois quarts, on voit l'état classique zéro, et en mesurant, on passe à ket zéro
comme état probabiliste,
et avec probabilité un quart, on passe à ket un.
Tu peux penser à cela comme une transition de connaissance si tu préfères, par opposition à une transition physique
réelle,
mais ce qui est important pour
les besoins de cette leçon, c'est de reconnaître comment les mathématiques fonctionnent.
C'est en quelque sorte trivial en réalité, mais en reconnaissant cette trivialité, la description analogue
pour le cadre quantique
pourrait sembler un peu moins mystérieuse.
Une dernière remarque est que pour une autre personne qui n'aurait pas vu quel
était l'état classique de X quand on l'a mesuré,
l'état probabiliste
ne changerait naturellement pas suite à notre mesure.
C'est normal. Différentes personnes peuvent
avoir différentes connaissances d'un système particulier et choisir en conséquence des états probabilistes différents
pour représenter leur
connaissance de ce système.
Dans la dernière partie de cette discussion sur l'information classique, nous parlerons des opérations classiques pouvant être effectuées sur un système,
en commençant par les opérations déterministes.
Lorsqu'on effectue une opération sur un système, son état change généralement en conséquence, et dans ce contexte, le mot déterministe signifie
que le résultat de l'exécution
de l'opération dépend entièrement de l'état classique dans lequel se trouvait le système
avant que l'opération soit effectuée.
En d'autres termes, il n'y a
pas d'élément de hasard quand une opération déterministe
est effectuée, il n'y a donc pas de caractère aléatoire
ni d'incertitude.
En termes mathématiques, les opérations déterministes
sont décrites par des fonctions.
Toute fonction f de la forme
que tu vois ici, ce qui signifie que l'entrée et la sortie de la fonction
correspondent à des éléments de
notre ensemble d'états classiques sigma décrit une opération déterministe.
L'état classique a est
transformé en l'état f de a pour chaque choix d'un état a.
Pour toute fonction f de cette forme, il existera toujours une unique matrice M satisfaisant cette condition
que tu vois ici,
à savoir que multiplier
M par le vecteur ket a nous donne le vecteur ket f de a,
et c'est vrai pour tout
choix d'un état classique a.
Il n'est pas trop difficile d'écrire
une description explicite de M étant donnée la fonction f
de cette forme que nous avons choisie.
Elle aura toujours exactement
un un dans chaque colonne avec toutes les autres entrées égales à zéro.
Et voici la formule. L'entrée b, a de M est égale à un si b est égal à f de a
et autrement, elle est égale à zéro, et par là, nous entendons
que c'est l'entrée de M dont la ligne correspond à b
et dont la colonne correspond à a.
WEBVTT
Nous allons voir quelques exemples dans un moment, et nous verrons pourquoi cette formule fonctionne.
Maintenant, il n'est peut-être pas évident de savoir pourquoi on voudrait prendre une fonction et l'exprimer comme une matrice comme ça,
mais ça a du sens de le faire. Une des raisons, et c'est peut-être la raison principale, c'est que si on a un système
dans un état probabiliste
et qu'on effectue une opération déterministe
sur ce système, alors l'état probabiliste résultant peut être obtenu
par une multiplication matrice-vecteur, c'est-à-dire que si notre système est
dans un état probabiliste
représenté par
un vecteur de probabilité v et qu'on effectue l'opération déterministe décrite par M
sur ce système, alors l'état probabiliste résultant sera donné par M fois v.
Ici, cette flèche avec une petite
barre dessus comme ça est juste une notation courante en mathématiques pour indiquer comment une
chose est transformée en
ou transformée en une autre chose. On pourrait juste utiliser une flèche ordinaire, mais c'est la convention
et c'est reconnaissable et c'est peut-être un peu plus précis qu'une simple flèche, qui peut signifier beaucoup de choses différentes.
Maintenant, examinons un exemple ou plutôt une collection d'exemples.
Voyons ce qui se passe quand on prend notre ensemble d'états classiques sigma comme étant à nouveau l'alphabet binaire.
Il n'y a pas beaucoup de fonctions différentes de la forme dont on a parlé quand c'est notre ensemble d'états classiques, et pour être plus précis, il y en a exactement quatre
de cette forme.
Voici ces quatre fonctions décrites par leurs tables de valeurs.
La première table décrit
la première fonction, que nous avons appelée f1.
Pour chaque entrée possible à gauche, on liste la sortie correspondante à droite, donc f1 de zéro est égal à zéro,
et f1 de un est, encore une fois, égal à zéro, et c'est-à-dire que f1 est
la fonction constante zéro.
Elle prend toujours la valeur zéro.
La deuxième fonction f2
est la fonction identité.
La sortie est toujours égale à l'entrée comme tu peux le voir dans la deuxième table.
La troisième fonction f3 est
décrite par la troisième table.
f3 de zéro est égal à un, et f3 de un est égal à zéro.
Cette fonction est plus
connue comme la fonction not ou la négation logique.
On l'appelle parfois aussi bit flip parce qu'elle transforme zéro
en un et un en zéro.
La dernière fonction f4 est,
encore une fois, une fonction constante comme la première, mais celle-ci est la fonction constante un
parce qu'elle prend toujours la valeur un.
Et ce sont les seules quatre fonctions de l'alphabet binaire vers lui-même.
Voici les quatre matrices qui correspondent à ces quatre fonctions, décrites par
la formule de tout à l'heure,
que tu peux voir ici, et si tu en as envie, tu peux mettre la vidéo sur pause et vérifier cela.
N'oublie pas qu'avec les matrices, l'ordre des indices est toujours lignes d'abord, colonne ensuite.
Donc l'entrée b, a correspond
à la ligne b et à la colonne a, ou la ligne qui correspond
à l'état classique b
et la colonne qui correspond
à l'état classique a.
Donc, par exemple, si on regarde
la première fonction, on a f1 de zéro est égal à zéro
et en conséquence, l'entrée
zéro, zéro de M1 est égale à un.
Eh bien, l'entrée un, zéro
qui est ici est égale à zéro, et on peut faire la même chose pour le cas
où l'entrée est égale à un et de façon similaire pour les
trois autres fonctions.
Tu peux également vérifier que cette
formule de tout à l'heure est vraie et tu peux passer en revue un par un toutes les différentes
possibilités pour le vérifier.
Et en fait, si tu réfléchis à la façon dont
la multiplication matricielle fonctionne, tu peux en quelque sorte le voir d'un coup d'œil.
Quand tu multiplies une matrice par un vecteur de base standard comme ça, tu peux imaginer que
tu prends l'entrée
et que tu la fais descendre dans le
haut de l'une des matrices dans la colonne qui correspond
à l'état classique
dans le ket, et la sortie que tu
obtiens est simplement cette colonne comme vecteur de probabilité.
Ainsi, par exemple, M3 multiplié par ket
zéro te donne zéro, un
comme vecteur de probabilité, ce qui est ket un.
M3 multiplié par ket
un te donne un, zéro, qui est ket zéro, etc.
Nous allons discuter des opérations sur
les états probabilistes dans un moment, mais d'abord, introduisons la deuxième partie de la notation de Dirac.
Cela va être utile
pour parler des opérations et les considérer comme des matrices, et c'est aussi un outil standard
que nous continuerons à utiliser par la suite. La configuration est identique à celle d'avant.
Nous avons l'ensemble d'états classiques sigma avec lequel nous travaillons et nous supposons avoir une façon d'
ordonner ces états classiques.
Nous écrivons alors cette chose
que tu vois ici où cette fois la
barre angulaire est à gauche plutôt qu'à droite pour signifier
le vecteur ligne ayant un un
dans l'entrée qui
correspond à a et un zéro pour toutes les autres entrées correspondant à tous les
autres états classiques.
Donc la différence entre
cette chose et ket a est que celle-ci est un vecteur ligne et
ket a est un vecteur colonne,
WEBVTT
mais sinon, les vecteurs
sont définis de façon similaire.
On lit ceci bra a, je ne sais pas si c'est censé être drôle, mais l'idée est que les noms bra et ket
sont les deux moitiés du mot bracket, et nous aurons plus à dire
à ce sujet dans un moment.
Mais d'abord, regardons
un exemple très rapide.
Pour l'alphabet binaire, bra zéro est
ce vecteur ligne ici analogue à ket a,
sauf que c'est un vecteur ligne
au lieu d'un vecteur colonne et bra un est ce vecteur ici.
Maintenant, en général, si on multiplie un vecteur
ligne par un vecteur colonne, en les considérant juste comme des matrices
qui n'ont qu'une
seule ligne ou juste une seule colonne, on obtient une matrice 1 par 1, qu'on peut penser
comme étant un scalaire.
Ici, d'ailleurs, tu devrais
penser à ces étoiles comme représentant des nombres arbitraires.
En particulier, si
on multiplie le vecteur ligne bra a par le vecteur colonne ket b,
alors deux choses peuvent se passer.
L'une est que a et b sont égaux, c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont le même état classique, auquel cas, les uns vont se retrouver alignés
et le produit sera égal à un, ou il pourrait être le cas
que a et b sont différents,
et donc les uns ne s'alignent pas et le produit est égal à zéro.
Une façon simple d'exprimer
ces observations est comme ça ici.
Et juste pour garder les choses bien rangées, on écrit ce produit comme ça avec juste une barre au milieu et ça signifie exactement la même
chose que ça ici.
Et maintenant tu peux voir comment le
bra et le ket se combinent pour former un bracket, ce qu'on appelle aussi un produit scalaire,
et c'est quelque chose
de très important sur lequel nous reviendrons
dans la leçon numéro trois.
Multiplier un vecteur colonne
par un vecteur ligne, en revanche, nous donne une matrice comme tu peux le voir ici.
Donc par exemple, en revenant encore
à l'alphabet binaire, si on multiplie ket zéro par bra zéro,
on obtient cette matrice ici, et on peut passer par les
autres possibilités pour voir ce qui se passe.
Ket zéro fois bra un nous donne
cette matrice ici où le un s'est maintenant déplacé
vers cette position.
Ket un, bra zéro ressemble à ça et voici ket un, bra un.
Ce qu'on voit se passer, c'est qu'il y a juste un seul un dans une matrice qui est sinon toute constituée de zéros, et la position de ce un
est déterminée par les
états classiques qu'on choisit dans le bra et le ket.
Plus précisément, et
cela est vrai en général, pour tout choix d'un ensemble d'états classiques, la matrice qu'on obtient en
multipliant ket a par bra b
est la matrice avec un un dans l'entrée a, b et un zéro pour toutes les autres entrées.
Et maintenant que nous avons les
première et deuxième parties de la notation de Dirac, nous disposons d'un outil très pratique pour relier les opérations aux matrices.
Revenons donc brièvement
aux opérations déterministes et rappelons qu'un peu
plus tôt dans la leçon,
il a été mentionné que pour toute fonction f de
cette forme ici, nous avons une opération déterministe qui transforme a en f de a
pour chaque état classique a possible. Et nous avons dit que pour
toute fonction comme ça, il existe toujours une unique
matrice M qui agit ainsi
sur les vecteurs de base standard.
En utilisant la notation de Dirac, on peut maintenant très facilement exprimer cette matrice comme tu le vois ici,
et on peut voir comment il est parfois
possible de travailler avec des matrices entièrement
dans le cadre de la notation de Dirac
sans jamais convertir explicitement
en vecteurs et matrices, c'est-à-dire des rectangles remplis de nombres.
Dans ce cas, on peut vérifier que la
formule requise est vraie en multipliant M par ket a.
On substitue notre
expression pour M comme ça et on peut supprimer les parenthèses et assembler le bra
b avec le ket a comme ça.
C'est parce que la multiplication
matricielle est linéaire, dans ce cas, par rapport au premier argument et elle est associative, donc on peut supprimer les parenthèses.
Et maintenant, en rappelant que nous avons un a fixe dont on parle pendant qu'on somme sur tous les
choix possibles de b,
ce bracket ici sera
toujours égal à zéro quand b n'est pas égal à a, donc il n'y aura pas de
contribution à la somme,
et quand b est égal à a, le bracket sera égal à un et donc il ne restera que
ce terme ici.
C'est la formule que nous voulions et nous avons donc une façon très agréable et simple d'exprimer une fonction comme une matrice.
En plus des opérations déterministes, nous avons aussi des opérations qui
elles-mêmes introduisent de l'aléatoire ou de l'incertitude sur l'état classique d'un système.
On utilise le terme opération probabiliste pour désigner des opérations comme ça, et pour être précis, quand on dit opération probabiliste,
on désigne des opérations qui
peuvent introduire de l'aléatoire, donc les opérations déterministes sont en fait un cas particulier
des opérations probabilistes
qui n'introduisent tout simplement pas
d'aléatoire.
Voici un exemple simple où
de l'aléatoire est introduit.
C'est une opération sur un seul bit. La façon dont elle fonctionne est que si l'état classique
du bit est zéro,
alors rien ne se passe. Le bit reste à zéro, mais si l'état classique
du bit est un, alors l'opération transforme le bit en zéro
WEBVTT
avec une probabilité égale à 1/2.
Il n'y a pas de nom particulier
pour cette opération, du moins pas que je sache.
C'est juste un exemple, mais on peut imaginer effectuer
cette opération sur un bit.
Tout comme les opérations déterministes, les opérations probabilistes peuvent
être représentées par des matrices et leurs actions sur les états probabilistes
sont données par une multiplication matrice-vecteur comme avant.
Cette fois, il n'est pas nécessairement vrai que les matrices aient exactement un un dans chaque colonne et des zéros ailleurs.
Les opérations probabilistes sont
plus généralement représentées par des matrices stochastiques.
Ce sont des matrices dont toutes les entrées sont des
nombres réels non négatifs et où les entrées de
chaque colonne somment à un.
C'est équivalent à dire
que les matrices stochastiques sont des matrices où chaque colonne
forme un vecteur de probabilité.
Ça a du sens quand tu réfléchis à
l'action d'une matrice sur un vecteur de base standard.
Tu considères l'état classique
que tu veux et tu imagines que tu fais descendre cet état dans le haut de la matrice dans la colonne qui correspond
à cet état classique,
et cette colonne te dit quel
est l'état probabiliste qui ressort comme vecteur de probabilité.
L'opération probabiliste
dans notre exemple, par exemple, est décrite par cette matrice ici.
Si on effectue cette opération
sur l'état classique zéro, alors l'état probabiliste qu'on obtient est donné par la première colonne,
qui est, encore une fois, l'état classique zéro ou de façon équivalente, l'état probabiliste où zéro apparaît avec probabilité un.
Si au lieu de ça on effectue cette opération sur l'état classique un, alors on randomise effectivement le bit et en conséquence, on obtient
ce vecteur de probabilité ici
où la probabilité pour
chacun des états possibles est égale à 1/2.
En général, si on effectue cette opération sur n'importe quel état probabiliste, l'effet est essentiellement
une moyenne pondérée entre les deux colonnes
parce que c'est ainsi que fonctionne la multiplication
matrice-vecteur.
C'est linéaire, donc on fait juste la moyenne des deux
résultats possibles en conséquence.
Quand on pense aux opérations probabilistes
de cette façon, il est naturel de les voir comme pouvant introduire ou injecter de l'aléatoire.
On peut juste lire les colonnes une par une et on peut voir l'aléatoire
qu'elles introduisent pour chaque état classique possible.
On peut aussi penser aux
opérations probabilistes de façon légèrement différente, à savoir comme des choix aléatoires d'opérations déterministes.
Par exemple, dans notre exemple, on peut considérer cette opération comme étant équivalente à
lancer une pièce de monnaie équilibrée
et soit effectuer la
fonction constante zéro, soit la fonction identité
chacune avec probabilité 1/2,
et tu peux voir cela reflété
ici par cette équation.
C'est toujours possible pour
toute opération probabiliste, et c'est assez intuitif.
Si tu as fait des choix aléatoires
dans le cadre d'un processus, tu pourrais toujours imaginer faire ces choix aléatoires à l'avance
et ensuite les coder en dur
dans une collection d'opérations déterministes.
Il est parfois très utile de penser aux opérations probabilistes
de cette façon, et nous en verrons un exemple
dans quelques leçons.
La dernière chose à dire
sur l'information classique pour cette leçon concerne la composition
des opérations probabilistes, ce qui signifie simplement les effectuer
l'une après l'autre.
Supposons que nous avons
un système nommé X et M1 à Mn sont des matrices stochastiques représentant des opérations probabilistes
sur X.
Imagine d'abord que nous avons
un vecteur de probabilité v, qui représente un état probabiliste de X à un moment donné, et qu'on applique d'abord
la première opération probabiliste à X, qui est représentée par la matrice M1, et puis on applique la deuxième
opération probabiliste,
qui est représentée par M2.
Si on fait ça, alors le
vecteur de probabilité qu'on obtient après avoir appliqué seulement la première
opération est M1 fois v,
et ensuite quand on applique
la deuxième opération, le vecteur de probabilité résultant est M2 multiplié par le vecteur qu'on a obtenu
après avoir appliqué M1. Ça ressemble à ça.
Maintenant, la multiplication
matricielle est une opération associative, ce qui signifie qu'il n'a pas d'importance où on met ces parenthèses.
Donc on pourrait tout aussi bien
mettre les parenthèses comme ça.
C'est très simple, mais c'est aussi intéressant parce que ça révèle qu'on peut
penser à l'opération où on applique d'abord M1
et ensuite M2
comme une seule opération.
En d'autres termes, l'
opération probabiliste qu'on obtient en composant les première et
deuxième opérations probabilistes est représentée par le
produit de matrices M2 fois M1,
et c'est la même opération quel que soit l'état probabiliste
avec lequel on a commencé.
Nous n'avons pas besoin de savoir quoi que ce soit sur le vecteur de probabilité v pour réfléchir à ou pour décrire
cette opération composée.
Remarque que l'ordre
ici est M2 à gauche et M1 à droite, ce qui est parce que la
matrice à droite, M1,
est celle qui est
multipliée par le vecteur v, tandis que M2 est multipliée
par le vecteur qu'on obtient après avoir multiplié par M1.
WEBVTT
Il faut donc toujours garder à l'esprit que l'ordre est en quelque sorte
inversé.
L'opération effectuée
en premier est celle à droite et l'opération effectuée en dernier, ou dans ce cas, en second,
est celle à gauche.
Si on ne s'arrête pas à la deuxième opération et qu'on les applique toutes dans
l'ordre en commençant par la première et en finissant par la dernière, qui est Mn,
alors la composition de toutes
ces opérations ensemble est donnée par ce produit
que tu vois ici,
et tu vois que l'ordre
est encore une fois inversé pour exactement la même raison qu'avant.
Donc en résumé, les compositions
d'opérations probabilistes sont représentées par des produits
de matrices stochastiques qui les représentent.
En gardant à l'esprit que c'est
l'ordre des matrices dans le produit.
On obtient toujours une matrice stochastique en prenant un produit de
matrices stochastiques comme ça, et parfois on exprime ce fait
en disant que les matrices
stochastiques sont fermées sous la multiplication, et la façon dont
tu peux penser à ça est que tu ne peux pas sortir de l'
ensemble des matrices stochastiques
en les multipliant parce que l'ensemble est fermé.
Pour en revenir à l'
ordre des matrices dans ce produit, il est important de noter que l'
ordre importe vraiment.
La multiplication matricielle n'est pas commutative. Si tu changes l'ordre des
matrices dans le produit, tu pourrais changer le résultat,
et nous n'avons pas besoin d'aller plus loin que les opérations déterministes
pour voir ça.
Voici un exemple simple de
deux matrices stochastiques, toutes deux représentant
des opérations déterministes où l'ordre importe.
M1 représente la fonction constante zéro. En supposant qu'on imagine que ces deux opérations portent sur des bits, comme dans l'exemple précédent.
M2 représente l'opération not
ou un bit flip.
Si on effectue M1 d'abord
et puis M2, le résultat est cette matrice ici, qui représente la
fonction constante un.
Si tu mets un bit à zéro
et que tu le retournes ensuite, c'est la même chose que de simplement
le mettre à un.
D'un autre côté, si on effectue M2 d'abord
et puis M1, voici le résultat ici,
et ça a du sens parce que si tu retournes un bit
et que tu le mets ensuite à zéro, c'est la même chose que de
simplement le mettre à zéro.
Peu importe que tu l'aies retourné. De toute évidence, ces deux
matrices ne sont pas les mêmes, et nous avons donc un exemple très
simple révélant
que l'ordre importe. Bien sûr, ce n'est pas surprenant du tout.
Nous savons tous que l'ordre dans lequel
les opérations sont effectuées importe, ou du moins, il peut importer.
Par exemple, si tu allumes une
allumette et que tu souffles dessus, le résultat est très différent
de souffler sur l'allumette d'abord
et puis l'allumer. À ce stade, nous avons beaucoup parlé
de l'information classique et il est enfin temps de
discuter de l'information quantique.
Et ce que nous allons trouver, c'est que
mathématiquement parlant, l'information quantique fonctionne
de façon très similaire à l'information classique
avec quelques différences clés.
La première différence clé
est dès le début, la façon dont on définit un état, dans ce cas, un état quantique d'un système,
et il y a en un sens
que ce seul choix, la façon dont
on définit un état quantique, détermine largement le fonctionnement
de l'information quantique.
Nous allons également définir comment
fonctionnent les mesures et les opérations, et dans la prochaine leçon, nous verrons comment
fonctionne l'information quantique non seulement pour des systèmes simples
mais pour des systèmes multiples,
mais ces choses découlent en fait
assez naturellement une fois que la notion d'état quantique d'un seul système en
isolation a été établie.
Voici la définition. Un état quantique d'un système est représenté par un vecteur colonne dont les indices sont mis
en correspondance avec les
états classiques de ce système.
Nous supposons donc ici que
le système dont on parle a un certain ensemble d'états classiques, tout comme quand on a parlé
de l'information classique
et des états probabilistes. Les entrées d'un vecteur d'état quantique sont des nombres complexes, par opposition au cas probabiliste
où les entrées sont des
nombres réels non négatifs.
Et cette fois, la somme des
valeurs absolues au carré des entrées doit être égale à un, par opposition à la somme étant égale à un
comme dans le cas probabiliste.
Les nombres complexes qui apparaissent
dans un vecteur d'état quantique sont parfois appelés amplitudes et jouent un rôle similaire aux probabilités,
mais ce ne sont pas des probabilités et ils n'ont pas la
même interprétation.
Je ne peux pas te donner une bonne raison pour laquelle les états quantiques
devraient être définis comme ça, sinon que les physiciens ont découvert
que cette définition
est physiquement pertinente et nous permet de décrire et de modéliser
des systèmes quantiques mécaniques.
En d'autres termes, on choisit cette définition
parce qu'elle fonctionne, et non parce qu'il y a des
raisons particulières pour lesquelles les états quantiques devraient
être définis comme ça.
En ce qui concerne les
mathématiques de cette notion d'état quantique, la première étape pour la comprendre et travailler avec elle est
de rappeler cette définition
pour la norme euclidienne d'un vecteur, qu'on peut penser géométriquement comme la longueur d'un vecteur, tout comme on penserait à la longueur
d'un vecteur réel en deux dimensions si on le dessinait sur une feuille de
papier comme une flèche partant de l'origine de la façon habituelle.
WEBVTT
Plus précisément, si nous avons un
vecteur colonne v comme ça, qui a selon notre hypothèse
des entrées de nombres complexes, alpha un à alpha n,
alors la norme euclidienne de v est définie comme tu le vois ici.
C'est la notation que nous
utilisons pour la norme euclidienne en mettant ces doubles barres autour du vecteur dont on parle.
Dans ce cas, c'est v, et la façon dont la norme euclidienne est définie est que c'est la racine carrée de la somme
des valeurs absolues au carré
des entrées du vecteur.
Donc une autre façon de définir ce qu'est
un vecteur d'état quantique est qu'un vecteur d'état quantique est un vecteur colonne ayant
des entrées de nombres complexes
dont la norme euclidienne est égale à un, c'est-à-dire que c'est un vecteur unitaire par rapport à la norme euclidienne.
C'est parce que la somme des
valeurs absolues au carré est égale à un si et seulement si la norme euclidienne
est égale à un.
La racine carrée ne change rien quand la somme des valeurs
absolues au carré est égale à un.
Voilà donc ce qu'est un vecteur d'état quantique. C'est un vecteur colonne avec des indices correspondant aux
états classiques d'un système
ayant des entrées de nombres complexes et une norme euclidienne égale à un.
Ce que ça signifie ou ce que ça implique ou comment on devrait interpréter cette
notion est une autre question et, dans un certain sens,
l'étude de l'information
et du calcul quantiques est une exploration de ce que
cette définition implique, du moins en termes de
traitement de l'information.
C'est simplement le point de départ.
À titre de remarque, il faut mentionner qu'il
existe d'autres normes dites en dehors de la norme euclidienne et cette notation
ici avec les doubles barres
autour d'un vecteur ne signifie pas toujours
la norme euclidienne.
Dans différents contextes, cette notation pourrait faire référence
à une norme différente.
Par exemple, la somme
des valeurs absolues sans carré ni racine carrée est une norme différente,
souvent appelée norme un. Il existe en fait beaucoup de
normes différentes.
Parfois, on voit
cette notation utilisée avec un indice après
le deuxième ensemble de barres qui fournit plus d'informations sur la norme dont on parle.
Et quand on fait ça, il est assez typique que le nombre deux comme indice
signifie la norme euclidienne.
Mais dans cette série, chaque fois que nous avons un
vecteur colonne comme ça, cette notation avec doubles barres toute seule
signifie la norme euclidienne.
Voici quelques exemples
de vecteurs d'état quantique et ces vecteurs d'état quantique particuliers sont des vecteurs d'état qubit,
ce qui signifie que les
états classiques de notre système sont zéro et un.
Le mot qubit est l'abréviation de bit quantique, qui est vraiment juste un bit
qui peut être dans un état quantique.
Les deux premiers exemples sont vraiment simples. Les vecteurs de base standard
ket zéro et ket un sont des vecteurs d'état quantique.
Ce sont tous les deux des vecteurs colonnes, et les indices correspondent
aux états classiques zéro et un, et les entrées de ces
vecteurs sont des nombres complexes.
Pour ces vecteurs particuliers, les entrées sont zéro et un, qui sont des nombres réels, et en fait ce sont des entiers, mais ce sont aussi des nombres complexes
dont la partie
imaginaire est égale à zéro.
Chaque vecteur a une entrée égale à un et une entrée égale à zéro.
Donc quand on somme les valeurs
absolues au carré des entrées, on obtient un dans les deux cas.
Donc les conditions
requises pour que ces vecteurs soient des vecteurs d'état quantique sont satisfaites.
Les deux exemples suivants sont des états qubit très couramment rencontrés appelés l'état plus et l'état moins.
Ils sont notés comme tu le
vois ici à l'écran, soit avec un ket plus
soit un ket moins comme ça, et ils sont définis comme
tu peux le voir ici.
Encore une fois, les entrées de ces
vecteurs sont des nombres complexes. Cette fois, elles sont soit plus un sur racine carrée de deux soit moins un sur racine carrée de deux,
et quand on somme les
valeurs absolues au carré, on obtient 1/2 plus 1/2, ce qui fait un.
À propos, mettre un
signe plus ou un signe moins à l'intérieur d'un ket comme ça
peut sembler un peu étrange parce que ce ne sont pas des
états classiques de notre système,
mais cette notation est utilisée malgré tout, et nous y reviendrons dans un moment.
Mais pour l'instant, en bref, on peut utiliser la notation de Dirac pour mettre n'importe quel nom qu'on veut pour un vecteur à l'intérieur d'un ket.
Le vecteur ne doit pas nécessairement
être un vecteur de base standard quand on utilise la notation de Dirac.
Voici un dernier exemple d'état qubit
pour l'instant.
C'est un vecteur d'état quantique d'un qubit qui n'a pas de nom particulier, et il n'est pas particulièrement significatif.
Les entrées de ce vecteur sont un plus deux fois i
sur trois et moins 2/3.
Ce sont des nombres complexes, et si tu calcules les
valeurs absolues au carré de ces deux entrées, tu obtiendras 5/9 pour la première
et 4/9 pour la deuxième. Donc la somme des valeurs absolues
au carré est égale à un.
Et voici un dernier exemple. Cette fois pour un système
dont les états classiques sont les quatre couleurs de cartes.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi on aurait un système dont les états classiques
sont les quatre couleurs de cartes dans un état quantique, mais c'est possible en principe
et c'est juste voulu comme un exemple.
WEBVTT
Les entrées correspondant
aux différentes couleurs sont 1/2 pour clubs, moins
i sur deux pour diamonds,
zéro pour hearts parce qu'il n'apparaît pas dans la somme et un sur racine
carrée de deux pour spades.
Et voici à quoi ça ressemble
comme vecteur colonne, en supposant qu'on a ordonné
les états classiques comme avant,
qui est l'ordre que
tu vois ici.
Prendre la valeur absolue
au carré de ces entrées donne un quart pour la première, aussi un quart pour la suivante.
La valeur absolue au carré
de zéro est égale à zéro, donc cette entrée ne
contribue pas à la somme.
Et enfin, pour la dernière, on obtient 1/2. Donc la somme est égale à un, comme requis pour que ce vecteur
soit un vecteur d'état quantique.
Il y a juste un moment, nous avons utilisé la notation
ket plus et ket moins pour faire référence à deux vecteurs d'état qubit qui ne sont pas des vecteurs de base standard.
Et je voudrais revenir
brièvement sur ce point et expliquer comment la notation de Dirac est utilisée pour des vecteurs arbitraires et pas seulement pour des vecteurs de base standard.
Comme je l'ai déjà mentionné, on peut utiliser n'importe quel nom qu'on
veut à l'intérieur d'un bra ou ket pour désigner un vecteur.
Les kets sont des vecteurs colonnes
et les bras sont des vecteurs lignes comme avant.
Par exemple, la lettre grecque
psi est très couramment utilisée à l'intérieur d'un ket pour désigner un vecteur arbitraire quelconque,
et ici, nous l'utilisons pour
donner un nom au vecteur d'état de tout à l'heure qui n'a pas
de nom particulier.
Quand on fait ça, la lettre psi n'a pas
nécessairement de signification en elle-même.
C'est juste le nom d'un vecteur, et il est à l'intérieur d'un ket pour nous aider à clarifier
que c'est un vecteur colonne.
Cela peut être un peu
déroutant parfois, et il y a un risque d'ambiguïté si la lettre psi pouvait être associée
à un état classique d'
un système par exemple, mais ça ne cause généralement pas de problèmes, et tu n'es pas obligé d'utiliser
la notation de Dirac comme ça
si tu ne le veux pas. Utiliser une lettre minuscule comme
u, v ou w sans ket est aussi une bonne façon de
désigner un vecteur colonne
ou plus précisément,
un vecteur d'état quantique.
C'est ton choix la notation
que tu utilises pour t'exprimer.
Tu dois juste t'assurer
que premièrement, le sens de ce que tu
essaies d'exprimer est clair pour les autres.
Et deuxièmement, que tu comprends ce que
les autres essaient d'exprimer même quand leurs préférences de notation ne sont pas les mêmes que les tiennes.
Il y a une règle très importante pour utiliser la notation de Dirac
pour des vecteurs arbitraires, à savoir que si tu as un vecteur colonne
que tu as décidé d'écrire
comme ket psi, par exemple, ou ça pourrait être un
nom différent à l'intérieur d'un ket, alors le vecteur ligne bra psi
est compris comme étant
le transposé conjugué du vecteur ket psi.
Et ici, c'est écrit comme une équation où ce dague ici fait référence au transposé conjugué.
Plus précisément, c'est
le vecteur ligne qu'on obtient en, premièrement, transposant le vecteur, ce qui signifie qu'on le retourne sur le côté et qu'on le change d'une colonne en une ligne
sans changer les entrées. Et deuxièmement, en prenant le conjugué complexe
de chacune des entrées.
On peut en fait effectuer
ces deux opérations, la transposée et le
conjugué complexe entrée par entrée dans n'importe quel ordre car
ces deux opérations commutent.
Donc pour le vecteur dans cet exemple, étant donné que nous avons décidé de
l'appeler ket psi, il est entendu que bra psi
signifie ce vecteur ici
où nous avons transposé le vecteur en transformant ket zéro et ket
un en bra zéro et bra un, et nous avons pris le conjugué complexe de chaque entrée,
c'est pourquoi un plus
deux fois i sur trois devient un moins deux
fois i sur trois ici.
Voici à quoi ressemblent ces vecteurs lorsqu'ils sont écrits
explicitement comme vecteur colonne et vecteur ligne.
Remarque, d'ailleurs, que
cette règle est cohérente avec la notation qu'on utilise quand on a des états classiques
à l'intérieur du bra et du ket.
Dans ce cas, les entrées sont
toutes zéro sauf un un, et donc prendre le conjugué complexe ne change rien dans ce cas.
Nous avons maintenant vu comment les états quantiques sont représentés comme des vecteurs, mais il n'est pas clair à ce
point ce que signifie ou quelles sont les implications
en termes de ce que
tu peux faire avec le système dans un état quantique ou comment tu peux interagir avec lui.
La première chose à faire pour mettre ces questions en perspective
est de discuter des mesures.
Intuitivement parlant,
les mesures fournissent un mécanisme pour extraire l'information classique
des systèmes quantiques.
Quand on regarde un système
quand il est dans un état quantique, on ne voit pas un état quantique tout comme on ne voit pas
des états probabilistes,
on voit des états classiques, et cette notion de mesure est ce qui fournit l'interface.
Si nous, en tant qu'humains, voulons savoir quelque chose sur un système quantique, nous devons le mesurer, et ce faisant, nous allons extraire de l'information classique
sur l'état quantique dans lequel
se trouvait ce système.
Il existe différentes
notions de mesures. La différence est vraiment une question de
généralité, et nous allons commencer par la plus simple et la plus basique,
qui est généralement appelée
mesure en base standard.
WEBVTT
Nous allons généraliser cela
dans les leçons suivantes. Nous parlerons des mesures projectives dans la leçon trois, et plus tard dans la
troisième unité de la série,
nous parlerons des mesures générales, également appelées mesures à opérateurs à valeurs positives ou POVMs en abrégé.
Mais pour l'instant, nous allons limiter notre attention aux mesures en base standard.
Lorsqu'une mesure est
effectuée sur un système, il y aura un certain ensemble
de résultats possibles de cette mesure, qui sont des résultats classiques,
et dans le cas d'une
mesure en base standard, ces résultats possibles sont
précisément les états classiques du système qui est mesuré.
Chacun de ces états classiques sera le résultat de la mesure avec une certaine probabilité, et cette probabilité est la valeur absolue au carré
de l'entrée correspondant
à cet état classique du vecteur d'état quantique dans lequel se trouvait le système juste avant d'être mesuré.
On sait que la valeur absolue au carré de tout nombre complexe est un nombre réel non négatif, et on sait par la définition
des vecteurs d'état quantique
que la somme des valeurs
absolues au carré des entrées d'un vecteur d'état quantique est égale à un.
Donc ça a du sens. Chaque état classique apparaîtra comme le résultat de la
mesure avec une certaine probabilité et les probabilités somment à un.
Voici quelques exemples. Supposons d'abord que nous avons un
qubit dans l'état plus.
Si on mesure ce qubit par rapport à une
mesure en base standard, on obtient soit un zéro soit
un comme résultat.
La probabilité d'obtenir un zéro est la valeur absolue
au carré de un sur racine de deux, ce qui est 1/2, et c'est la même
probabilité d'obtenir un.
Donc si tu mesures un état plus, tu obtiendras un bit aléatoire uniforme.
Si le système est dans un état moins
plutôt que dans un état plus, alors la mesure fonctionne de
exactement la même façon.
Les probabilités sont, encore une fois, 1/2 pour chaque résultat possible.
La seule différence ici est que le signe plus est devenu un signe moins, mais quand on prend la valeur
absolue, rien ne change.
Si on mesure cet état qubit, la probabilité d'obtenir le résultat zéro est la valeur absolue au carré de un plus deux fois i
sur trois, ce qui est 5/9,
et la probabilité d'obtenir le résultat un est la valeur absolue au carré
de moins 2/3, ce qui est 4/9.
Et enfin, mesurer
l'état de base standard, ket zéro donne le résultat
zéro avec certitude, et de même, mesurer l'état ket un
donne le résultat un avec certitude. C'est parce que la valeur
absolue au carré de un est un.
Similaire à ce que nous avions dans
le cadre probabiliste. On peut associer ces états quantiques, ket zéro dans ket un, au système se trouvant dans
ces états classiques,
et cet exemple est cohérent
avec cette interprétation.
Maintenant, tout comme dans
le cadre probabiliste, si on mesure un système quand
il est dans un état quantique,
l'état va changer, en général, suite à l'exécution
de cette mesure.
En particulier, et encore une fois, c'est exactement comme dans
le cadre probabiliste.
Si on mesure un système et que le résultat de la mesure
est l'état classique a, alors le nouvel état quantique
du système devient ket a.
Donc pour cet état ici,
par exemple, on voit le même type
de comportement qu'on avait dans le cadre probabiliste.
Si on mesure alors avec probabilité 5/9, on obtient le résultat zéro, auquel cas l'état
passe à ket zéro,
et avec probabilité
4/9, le résultat est un, et l'état passe à ket un.
Parfois, ce phénomène est désigné comme un effondrement
de l'état quantique, et c'est le genre de chose qui empêche les gens
qui étudient les fondements
de la mécanique quantique de dormir la nuit.
Mais d'un point de vue purement
mathématique, c'est vraiment assez simple
et très analogue à ce que nous avons dans le cas probabiliste.
La source de tension ici, dans un certain sens, concerne la nature fondamentale des états quantiques et ce qu'ils représentent
et comment ils diffèrent
des états probabilistes. Mais au niveau mathématique, c'est peut-être ce qu'on pourrait attendre.
Remarque, d'ailleurs, que si
tu mesures une deuxième fois, tu obtiendras exactement
le même résultat qu'à la première mesure.
Il y a donc une limite sur la quantité d'
information classique pouvant être extraite d'un état quantique, et nous reviendrons sur ce point bientôt
dans une autre leçon. Nous avons parlé des états quantiques ainsi que des mesures, en particulier des mesures en base standard,
qui fournissent un moyen d'
extraire l'information classique des états quantiques.
Le sujet restant pour
cette leçon est les opérations, plus précisément les opérations unitaires, qui décrivent comment
les états quantiques des systèmes
peuvent être modifiés. Naturellement, étant donné que les
vecteurs d'état quantique sont différents des vecteurs de probabilité, on s'attendrait à ce que l'ensemble des opérations autorisées
sur les états quantiques soit différent de ce que nous avons pour
l'information classique, et effectivement, c'est le cas.
Alors que les opérations sur les états probabilistes sont représentées par des matrices stochastiques, les opérations sur les vecteurs d'état quantique
sont représentées par des matrices unitaires.
Voici la définition des matrices unitaires.
Une matrice carrée U ayant des entrées de
nombres complexes est unitaire si elle satisfait les égalités
que tu vois ici.
WEBVTT
Le dague représente
le transposé conjugué, que nous avons déjà vu pour les vecteurs quand nous avons parlé de la
notation de Dirac il y a quelques instants.
Ici, nous effectuons le
transposé conjugué sur une matrice plutôt que sur un vecteur, mais c'est essentiellement la même chose.
On transpose la matrice, ce qui signifie simplement qu'on
échange les lignes et les colonnes, donc l'entrée JK devient l'entrée KJ,
et on prend aussi le conjugué complexe de chaque entrée.
Aussi, cette notation ici
signifie la matrice identité.
Ces deux égalités ici
sont en fait équivalentes. Si tu en as une, alors tu as
automatiquement l'autre.
Elles sont toutes deux équivalentes à
dire que U est inversible, et que l'inverse est égal
au transposé conjugué.
Cela n'est vrai que pour les matrices
carrées, d'ailleurs. Si tu as une matrice qui n'est pas carrée, alors l'une de ces deux
égalités pourrait être vraie,
mais alors l'autre ne sera pas vraie.
Mais ici, nous parlons
de matrices carrées.
C'est donc la définition standard
pour les matrices unitaires, et c'est pratique parce qu'il est facile de vérifier
si une matrice est unitaire.
Tu multiplies simplement la matrice par son transposé conjugué des deux côtés, et tu vois si tu obtiens
la matrice identité.
Il y a une façon équivalente de caractériser les matrices unitaires, à savoir qu'une
matrice carrée est unitaire si et seulement si elle ne change jamais la norme euclidienne
d'un vecteur quand on multiplie. Une matrice N par N U est unitaire si et seulement si la
norme euclidienne de U fois v
est égale à la norme euclidienne de v pour tout vecteur colonne de dimension n v ayant des entrées de nombres complexes.
Et par conséquent, si v est
un vecteur d'état quantique, alors U fois v est aussi
un vecteur d'état quantique parce que les vecteurs d'état quantique
sont simplement les vecteurs ayant
une norme euclidienne égale à un.
En fait, on peut dire un peu plus, à savoir que les matrices unitaires sont précisément les matrices qui transforment toujours les vecteurs d'état quantique
en vecteurs d'état quantique. C'est une situation similaire à celle que nous avons pour les matrices stochastiques
et les vecteurs de probabilité.
Les matrices stochastiques
sont précisément les matrices qui transforment toujours les vecteurs de probabilité en vecteurs de probabilité.
Donc une fois qu'on a décidé que les opérations devraient être représentées par des matrices, ce qui revient à dire que les transformations agissent linéairement
sur les vecteurs représentant les états, ces choix pour les ensembles
d'opérations autorisées découlent naturellement, du moins,
d'un point de vue mathématique.
Voyons maintenant quelques exemples d'opérations unitaires qubit.
Nous verrons beaucoup plus d'exemples
d'opérations unitaires dans les leçons suivantes, notamment des opérations unitaires sur des systèmes
ayant plus de deux états classiques. Mais pour l'instant, nous allons nous concentrer uniquement
sur les opérations unitaires qubit.
Nous allons voir ces
exemples particuliers apparaître encore et encore, donc ça vaut vraiment la peine de se familiariser
avec ces opérations.
La première collection d'exemples sont les opérations dites de Pauli.
Ce sont les opérations qui correspondent aux matrices de Pauli, qui sont présentées ici.
Elles sont toutes unitaires, et tu peux le vérifier pour chacune selon la définition précédente.
Ces matrices particulières
se trouvent être égales à leurs propres transposés conjugués, ce qui dit qu'elles sont
toutes des matrices hermitiennes.
Donc vérifier qu'elles sont
toutes unitaires, dans ce cas, est une question de mettre chacune au carré et de voir que le résultat
est la matrice identité.
Les noms que tu vois pour ces
matrices sont assez standards, et tu verras aussi sigma
x, sigma y et sigma z simplement appelés X, Y et Z.
Sois conscient, cependant, que les
lettres majuscules X, Y et Z sont aussi couramment utilisées à d'autres fins, même dans le contexte de
l'information quantique,
mais ce sont des noms très courants
pour ces matrices.
L'opération sigma x ou X
est aussi appelée bit flip ou opération not, que nous avons déjà vue
dans le contexte classique.
Et l'opération sigma z ou Z
est aussi appelée phase flip.
Et ici, tu peux voir l'
action de ces opérations sur les vecteurs de base standard, ce qui explique en quelque sorte
d'où viennent ces noms.
Certes, il est logique de
désigner sigma x comme bit flip d'après cette action ici.
Il retourne simplement le bit de
zéro à un ou de un à zéro.
Il est aussi logique de
désigner sigma z comme phase flip d'après cette action ici.
Mais si ce n'est pas tout à fait clair
pour l'instant, c'est normal.
Nous rencontrerons cette
opération encore et encore et la signification
de mettre un signe moins devant le vecteur de base ket un
et pas ket zéro
et pourquoi on l'appelle phase flip sera plus clair plus tard.
L'exemple suivant est
l'opération Hadamard, qui est représentée par
cette matrice ici, qui est presque toujours nommée H.
Vérifier que H est unitaire est encore une fois un
calcul direct, que si je m'écarte, tu peux voir ici.
Similaire aux matrices de Pauli, H est son propre transposé conjugué.
Donc nous avons cette égalité ici, et quand on effectue la multiplication, on obtient la matrice identité comme requis.
WEBVTT
Le troisième exemple est
en réalité une classe entière d'opérations unitaires
appelées opérations de phase.
Ce sont des opérations
représentées par n'importe quelle matrice prenant cette forme
que tu vois ici où theta est n'importe quel nombre réel.
Donc cette entrée ici sera
toujours un nombre complexe sur le cercle unité.
Les matrices comme ça sont toujours unitaires, ce que je te laisse vérifier.
Cette fois, le transposé conjugué ne sera pas égal à la matrice originale à moins que ce nombre ici ne soit un un ou un moins un,
auquel cas, on obtient
soit la matrice identité, soit sigma z, que nous avons
déjà rencontrée.
Plus précisément, la transposée
ne fera rien à cette matrice, mais prendre le conjugué complexe de chaque entrée change cette entrée ici
en e puissance moins i theta.
Ces deux opérations particulières ici sont des exemples particulièrement importants
d'opérations de phase.
Pour la première, on prend
theta égal à pi sur deux, et on obtient cette matrice ici.
Celle-ci est généralement appelée une
opération S ou un gate S quand on parle de circuits, que nous n'aborderons pas dans cette leçon,
mais c'est un
sujet important qui arrive bientôt.
Le deuxième est cette opération. C'est une opération T ou un gate T.
Et pour celui-ci, theta
est égal à pi sur quatre. Et donc quand on calcule l'exponentielle, on obtient cette valeur ici, qui est un plus i sur
la racine carrée de deux.
Voici juste quelques exemples rapides pour voir quelques-unes de ces
opérations en action.
Voici l'action de
l'opération Hadamard sur ket zéro et ket un.
Si on effectue la
multiplication matrice-vecteur, on voit qu'on obtient l'état plus et l'
état moins respectivement.
Si on effectue l'opération Hadamard sur l'état plus et l'
état moins, d'un autre côté, on revient à ket zéro et ket un.
Donc si on nettoie un peu les choses, on peut voir l'action plus clairement.
L'opération Hadamard
transforme dans les deux sens entre l'état zéro et l'état plus et entre l'état un
et l'état moins.
En ce qui concerne ces deux équations ici, remarque que cela nous donne un moyen simple de détecter la différence entre un état plus et un état moins.
Comme nous l'avons vu plus tôt dans la leçon, si on mesure un état plus
et un état moins par rapport à la
mesure en base standard,
on obtient un bit aléatoire uniforme dans les deux cas, ce qui ne nous aide pas à
détecter la différence.
Mais si on effectue une opération Hadamard et qu'on mesure ensuite, on verra un zéro si l'
état original était un état plus
et un un si l'état original
était un état moins.
Donc ces deux états sont effectivement différents, et ils peuvent être discriminés
parfaitement par la méthode que je viens de décrire,
qui consiste à effectuer d'abord
une opération Hadamard et puis à mesurer.
En revenant à l'exemple d'un
état qubit que nous avons vu avant qui n'est pas particulièrement spécial, on peut voir ce que l'opération Hadamard
fait à l'état
en convertissant aux formes
que tu vois ici et en effectuant la multiplication.
Et voici le résultat
qu'on peut reconvertir en notation de Dirac si on le souhaite,
et c'est une façon de calculer
ces types d'actions.
Voici un autre exemple qui illustre qu'on n'est pas toujours obligé
de convertir explicitement vers une forme matrice-vecteur.
On peut aussi effectuer ces
calculs directement en utilisant la notation de Dirac.
Cet exemple concerne l'opération T, et la voici
ici juste pour référence.
Cette opération a cette action ici sur les états de base standard.
Et si on veut calculer
l'action de l'opération T sur un état plus, par exemple, on peut commencer par développer la
définition de l'état plus
et puis utiliser la linéarité
pour exprimer le résultat comme tu le vois ici.
On peut maintenant juste substituer
ces expressions ici, faire juste un peu de
simplification pour le deuxième terme, et on obtient le résultat.
Si pour quelque raison que ce soit on voulait appliquer une opération Hadamard
au résultat, on peut faire une chose similaire.
D'abord, on substitue l'expression pour T agissant sur l'état plus et on utilise la linéarité comme on l'a fait avant.
Et maintenant, si on substitue les
expressions qu'on a déjà pour l'opération Hadamard
agissant sur ket zéro et ket un,
on obtient ça. Et maintenant, on peut développer l'état plus et l'état moins pour obtenir cette expression ici,
qu'on peut simplifier simplement en additionnant, et voici le résultat final.
Il n'y a rien de particulièrement
spécial dans cet exemple. C'est juste pour
illustrer cette façon alternative mais équivalente de
calculer les actions
de ces opérations. Tu peux utiliser la façon
qui est la plus pratique dans la situation en question.
Un dernier point sur
les opérations unitaires est que les compositions d'opérations unitaires sont représentées par la multiplication matricielle
comme dans le cadre probabiliste, c'est-à-dire qu'on peut calculer l'action d'une séquence d'opérations unitaires
en multipliant simplement
les matrices ensemble. Et ce qu'on obtiendra est
une seule matrice unitaire représentant l'action combinée
WEBVTT
de la séquence d'opérations.
Tout comme pour les matrices stochastiques, les matrices unitaires sont
fermées sous la multiplication, donc on obtiendra toujours une matrice unitaire
quand on compose des opérations unitaires.
Tu dois t'assurer
de multiplier les matrices dans le bon ordre.
Mais la façon dont ça fonctionne est exactement comme pour les
opérations stochastiques où la matrice pour la
première opération qu'on effectue
apparaîtra toujours sur le côté droit
du produit de matrices, et la dernière apparaîtra
sur le côté gauche.
Donc comme avant, l'ordre est inversé dans le sens où on compose de droite à gauche plutôt que de gauche à droite.
Voici un exemple intéressant qui donne lieu à une opération connue comme l'opération racine carrée de not.
Suppose qu'on applique d'abord
une opération Hadamard suivie d'une opération S, suivie d'une autre opération Hadamard.
L'action combinée de
ces trois opérations est décrite par ce produit.
Voici la première opération Hadamard, voici l'opération S, et voici la deuxième opération Hadamard.
Si on effectue la multiplication matricielle, qui n'est pas montrée ici explicitement, mais tu peux le faire
toi-même si tu veux,
le résultat est cette matrice ici. C'est une matrice unitaire, et on peut le vérifier directement
ou on peut se fier au fait que les matrices unitaires sont
fermées sous la multiplication.
Elle doit être unitaire parce que ces trois matrices sont unitaires, comme on l'a déjà vu.
Nous n'avons pas de vecteur d'état quantique particulier
en tête ici.
On peut imaginer effectuer
cette séquence d'opérations sur n'importe quel vecteur d'état quantique, et cette matrice décrit l'action.
La raison pour laquelle cette opération combinée, c'est-à-dire celle décrite
par cette matrice ici, est appelée opération racine carrée de not,
c'est qu'en l'effectuant
deux fois, on obtient une opération not, ou en d'autres termes, une
opération sigma x ou X.
Effectuer l'opération
deux fois est représenté par le carré de la matrice ou
en la multipliant par elle-même.
Et si tu fais ça, tu verras que le résultat
est la matrice de Pauli x.
Et c'est un peu particulier, et ça te donne juste un indice que tu peux faire des choses intéressantes avec l'information quantique qu'on ne peut pas faire avec
l'information classique.
Il n'y a pas d'opération classique, c'est-à-dire représentée
par une matrice stochastique, qui nous donne une opération not
si on l'effectue deux fois.
C'est donc un bon exemple qui révèle que les opérations quantiques
se comportent très différemment des opérations classiques.
Et c'est tout pour la leçon un. Dans cette leçon, nous avons discuté du fonctionnement de l'information quantique pour les systèmes simples en isolation,
et dans la prochaine leçon, nous verrons comment
fonctionne l'information quantique pour les systèmes multiples.
Merci de regarder. Si tu as des questions, n'hésite pas à les laisser dans
la section des commentaires ci-dessous.